hi i'm mia i'm seven
today i have two sets compete to make my
dream dish
hi how are you hi mia i'm alexis i'm
marcus
high five
hey everybody my name is chef marcus
samson from red rooster in harlem he
is the top of the line best of the best
honestly i'm just excited to
cook next time do you like mermaids yes
so cool so we have a big question if you
were a mermaid what kind of cake would
you want
vanilla can you draw it for us i am
right now
yeah absolutely are there shells are
there
berries not berries scary berries
no scary berries do you like
strawberries yeah
what about pineapples not pineapple
do you like raspberries i have coarse
raspberries
i feel the same way the flavors that me
has talked about vanilla and fruit are
also the flavors that i like so i feel
pretty good about this
what color would the decoration have
blue blue
why did you choose blue for your cake it
has lots of blueberries
because you like blueberries and also
what was the theme eating cakes
should we help you draw this in with
this book right here what would you like
us to draw here
vanilla vanilla cake with candles
i guess the show is now we draw we cook
i don't hate it hey man i haven't been
in drawing class for a long time so that
was fun
six leggers six players i only got
i got four so i got work to do you need
seven oh seven
i don't think i have room for seven how
many candles do you want on it twenty
twenty i got you she asked for twenty
candles
six or seven layers i'm gonna give her
some sparkles and candles
not focusing on how many what happens if
you don't get 20 candles
i'll cry oh don't cry
nothing to cry about him i love you too
do you want anything that is not blue on
this cake pink
you want pink with some poop
that's definitely interesting everything
up until this point has been
really kid-friendly really doable and
then mia said she wanted
poop i'm gonna focus on the pink i'm
gonna let alexis focus on the poop i
feel like this is super helpful and i
think we can make you something great
a barbie maybe not a barbie
we're gonna go and cook we're gonna make
you this fabulous mermaid cake
and you keep drawing okay okay all right
see you soon
see if i can get out of here
so here's my plan i'm starting with the
sand ocean strawberries popcorn
seaweed then you go to the next thing
which is the
chocolate pancake two ice creams the
whipped cream and then the
star dust that rains on top of it and on
top of that you have the birthday
element which is
two different types of candles and
sparklers all of it
there you have it so here's the game
plan i'm gonna make a crepe cake and dye
it blue so
every layer will be blue i'm gonna dye
whipped cream also a pale blue to put
that in between and then i'm gonna top
it all with berries it'll be pretty
simple but i think it'll hit
all the flavors that mia wants
i look very boring right now but you
have this amazing apron what's the story
yeah this is a beautiful charity that i
love alex lemonade
stand that supports and help young
children with cancer
that's incredible it's beautiful great
cause let's get cooking
all right i want to add lots of color to
my
dessert and raspberry strawberries a
little bit of blueberry
could be a fun way to just add color but
also good texture
totally so in here is vanilla bean i
just added in a little bit of cream
and coconut flakes and coconut milk i'm
going to put some more chocolate into it
later on
nutella nutella is like the way to kid's
heart right that was
i'm just making my crepe batter which is
just flour sugar eggs
milk and butter so my crepe batter is
done it's really smooth and i'm going to
dye it i grew up eating grapes it's one
of my favorite things to eat on a sunday
morning so this dish
i mean i love it i probably wouldn't dye
it blue but it's okay
where do mermaids live at sea
in the sea yeah have you ever seen one
no would you like to see one
yeah we have our beach and the bottom of
the ocean
right here and a color like it looks
amazing
oh my god she's gonna love it
we don't know that i mean i love it
marcus has all these different elements
and all these flavors going on and i'm
just
making grapes i want a batter that's
pretty loose but not
too liquidy you can see that the edge
starts to cook and that's kind of your
queue you know when to flip it this is
all i'm going to be doing i'm so sorry
so what's going to be in the
pancake is butter and chocolate then a
little bit of flour
uh some eggs and egg white this is going
to be done
when you can basically turn it upside
down marcus was definitely showing off a
little
by whipping the egg whites by hand but
honestly i don't find them i'm old
school my grandmother is the one who
taught me how to cook
and i like to whip things by hand
especially when you're making desserts
it's so important with texture and i've
never cooked in this kitchen so i won't
have total control over it i haven't
cooked an electric for a minute so this
is good
this is a good test okay you're gonna be
the taste
thank you marcus gives me
a bite of his pancake and then i
promptly dropped it
i'm gonna deal with this i'll be back i
just had to get a new pan
after my pancake mishap i just let that
heat up
marcus whipped his egg whites by hand
i'm making whipped cream with a mixer
much faster much nicer would you ever
want to be a mermaid
yeah yeah what would be the best part of
being a mermaid
the tail you're already a fish because
you like to swim
yeah can you imagine if you had a tail
that made you swim even faster
yes the idea with this plate is to
create a beach
but the pebbles here are strawberries
popcorn
seaweed and the sugar is going to
represent the sand and you know how you
feel when you come up you have sand
between your toes and sometimes you like
it and sometimes you don't
it's far more creative than mine it's
blue i was pretty set on my idea that i
wanted to build a sandy
really big rocky ocean i was just more
worried if i could do good enough jobs
so
me i would understand it i don't know if
she would get it but i had fun making it
and it was good
okay i'm finally done 24 grapes okay i'm
putting layers of this blue
whipped cream between the crepes and
just keep stacking it up you want to try
to make sure that the whipped cream is
even so the cake isn't lopsided but i
find it to be kind of soothing
just keep going what color would your
tail be
green no other color with some blue in
it there's some glitter
oh definitely glitter but not too
glittery
yeah not too glittery so i added two
types of food coloring for the top layer
so it looks like a little
marbled if you get up close or like
waves
it just looks fully like a smurf cake
right now i'm nervous if me are
really gonna like my sauce because it's
tart and sour
the strawberries are not very sweet
either i'm serious doubts
i mean it's really good but it's a tough
one
it worked kind of more as my clue but i
liked it and that is important too
oh that's that might help it oh we don't
know
mia said she really likes fruit so i'm
just gonna do a really really simple
fruit decoration on top which hopefully
she'll really like
the berries actually looked like a wave
and then i felt like
oh this could actually be really good i
also have basil
it's not like seaweed but maybe it'll be
reminiscent of seaweed
just to like make it a tiny bit prettier
okay i'm gonna step away
i think it's done palladium is always
nerve-wrecking and it's a lot of moving
parts
i wanted to build this like hilly beach
and then the dry ice gotta work
and then the sparkles gotta work so i'm
kind of nervous i'm gonna get this
together it's just all gonna fall down
because all this part needs to work
otherwise you don't get that dramatic
effect let's see what mia thinks yeah
i'm kind of nervous me too all right
wish me luck
oh me too
my crepe k is really simple but it hits
all the notes she wanted
vanilla berries that's pretty much it so
hopefully she likes this
simple interpretation of a mermaid cake
all i kept thinking about was that
moment when i'm gonna present the
dessert for mia and she would be like
yes i'm at the candy store i'm at a
circus and it's fun
if you don't go those eyes i fail
basically
look at that what do you think of that
good mom is that what you pictured in
your head when you drew that picture
yeah are you gonna blow out the candles
what's your wish it's a barbie a
barbecue one two three go
yay how fun it's like a birthday cake
what's this i don't know i'll try it
is it good yeah you love it this looks
like
sand doesn't it what does it taste like
it tastes like mermaid you have to try
the strawberry
it's so delicious mmm it is
really good it's really good what part
do you like the best
it's hot the top part yeah
i like napkin do you like it yeah
does it look like you're drawing no so
what are your thoughts about this
dessert
it's yummy okay you living your best
life right now
yeah yeah i'm happy that me i loved it
and it was fun to make oh my goodness
that's beautiful blueberries
those are your favorite does it look
like you're drawing
yeah excited
how okay it delicious yes
can i try this off here no
okay i didn't want to ruin the pretty
cake
it's so creamy what do you think
it's yummy yes should i have a
blackberry of course
oh it has cream it's yummy
it's so good huh does it taste like
something a mermaid would be
want one last bite no thanks mom you
have it
mia really likes both desserts i
genuinely don't know who she's gonna
choose but
the fact that she liked the cake in the
first place it just makes me so happy
okay mia we have a big question for you
out of both of the cakes
which one did you like better the sandy
one the sandy
one marcus made that one that's good
congratulations
thank you very much yay this is going
straight up on the wall in the
restaurant right next to the beard
awards
i like it i mean it makes me really
happy i feel like the happiest
loser ever i mean mia happy that's a win
in my book
you know you know what i have for you no
because you like my apron
it's lemon yeah i'm gonna give that to
you
when you i know it's big but when you
cook at home you can have that that's
yours
thank you so much it was so much fun
hanging with you thanks mia can i get a
high five too
yeah anytime you can cook for a child
and make a child happy
you should do it